man that Alex Jones fell just can't
catch a break he can't use a fake
bankruptcy to avoid billions of dollars
of awards to these Sandy Hook victims I
have $130,000 under penalty of perjury
there's no hidden accounts there's
nothing in the Cayman there's nothing
you know on the moon there's nothing yes
after years of spreading vicious lies
and baseless conspiracy theories about
the sany Hook massacre Jones was found
liable to the victim's families for $1.5
billion but Jones thought he discovered
that one weird trick to weasel out of
paying the people he hurt declaring
bankruptcy I declare nope do not cut to
that video it's too easy yeah except
that a judge in Texas just shot down
that effort declaring that as a matter
of law at least $1 billion of Jones's
judgment debts cannot be wiped Away by
bankruptcy why oh why do bad things a
very occasionally happen to bad people
so let's look at how Alex Jones tried to
use bankruptcy law to avoid paying
billions of dollars and why that effort
failed so spectacularly now if you want
a more detailed account of Alex Jones
and the Santa hook trials you can check
out some of this Channel's other videos
on the subject including the video I did
where explained how attorney Mark
Bankston absolutely destroyed Jones on
cross-examination but to quickly
summarize for years Alex Jones described
the 2012 Sandy Hook massacre as a hoax
and part of a secret government plot to
take your guns Jones's lies Unleashed a
wave of harassment on the victim's
families who are very much real uh
triggering multiple civil lawsuits
against him for defamation intentional
infliction of emotional distress and
other torts in late 2022 a kinectic jury
awarded $965 million in compensatory
damages and $473 million in punitive
damages to the families of 26 people who
were killed in the 2012 shooting plus an
FBI agent who was among the First
Responders in August of 2022 a Texas
jury found Jones liable for 4.2 million
in compensatory damages and 45.2 million
in punitive damages to Neil heslin and
Scarlet Lewis whose six-year-old son was
killed at Sandy Hook and before that in
October 2021 a Texas judge found Jones
liable for defamation against Leonard
pner an ex-wife veronique delar Rosa
whose six-year-old son was also killed
the pair are still waiting for a trial
on damages in all three cases the courts
had entered default judgments against
Jones based on repeated violations of
Discovery orders resulting in Jones
being a judged liable on all causes of
action without trial yeah that's what we
like to call here a huge fafo alert but
Jones had made it clear that he had no
intention of ever paying his victims
calling the damage Wards hilarious and
telling his audience he plans to file
appeals to keep the victims in court for
years Jones also claims he's officially
out of money having repeatedly begged
his audience to send him money to keep
him on the air and to that effect free
speech systems Jones's company that runs
Infowars declared bankruptcy in July
2022 and Jones filed for personal
bankruptcy in December and since many
people's understanding of bankruptcy is
limited to knowing that's how you lose a
monopoly here's a quick explainer filing
for bankruptcy provides a legal process
for the reduction or elimination of
certain debts in bankruptcy court
parties debts including those incurred
by Court judgments are categorized as
either dischargeable or
non-dischargeable depending on how they
were incurred if the court deems a debt
to be disar chargeable the debtor is no
longer personally liable for the
underlying debt and is excused from any
obligation to pay common examples of
dischargeable debts include credit card
and medical debt in contrast
non-dischargeable debts cannot be
extinguished in bankruptcy typically for
Public Policy reasons section 523 of the
bankruptcy code lists examples of
non-dischargeable debt such as domestic
support and tax obligations now
ultimately Jones wants to have part or
all of his $1.5 billion in judgments
declared dischargeable so he and his
company no longer have to pay them but
to prevent Jones from erasing his
judgment debts the sanah plaintiffs
formally intervened in the bankruptcy
process now of course if you're ever hit
with a $ 1.5 billion defamation judgment
you're going to need a good lawyer but
if you want a great lawyer my firm the
eagle team can help if you've been in a
car crash dealt with sexual harassment
or suffered from cancer we can represent
you or help find you the right attorney
who can it's so important to talk to a
lawyer early to make sure you get the
maximum recovery and choose the right
options so just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you you need the eagle team
the link is down below in March of 2023
The sany Hook plaintiffs from
Connecticut in Texas filed four
adversary complaints against Jones and
Free Speech systems in the bankruptcy
court in these complaints s Hood
plaintiffs alleged the Judgment debts
are non-dischargeable pursuant to the
bankruptcy code section 523 A6 which
excludes from discharge any debt that
was the result of a quote willful and
malicious injury against another the
families and other critics believe that
Jones is abusing the bankruptcy process
to Welch on his debts and back in March
Jones was accused of transferring up to
to $10 million to friends and family
members to put it beyond the reach of
creditors and contrary to Jones's
Newfound claims of poverty in August
2023 Court filing from the victim's
families paints quite the opposite
picture detailing Jones's hundreds of
thousands of dollars in lavish spending
so the sany hook plaintiffs moved for
summmer judgment against Alec Jones to
prevent the $1.5 billion in judgment
debts from being discharged I.E expunged
through bankruptcy and a moving party is
entitled to summary judgment upon
showing that there is no genuine dispute
as to any material fact that might
affect ffect the outcome of the suit and
thus the matter does not need to be
decided by a full trial judges may also
Grant a partial summary judgment by
ruling on some factual issues while
leaving others for trial and in separate
State specific motions the Texas and
Connecticut plaintiffs argue that the
state court records establish that
requisite Undisputed facts to conclude
that Jones inflicted willful and
malicious injuries on the parties and
that the Judgment debts arising out of
such conduct are non-dischargeable as a
matter of law the plaintiffs further
argu that Jones is barred from retiga
the finding that his conduct was willful
and malicious under the principle of
collateral LEL because those facts were
conclusively established before a
different Court that's one of those
rules that prevent someone that lost in
court to go to a different jurisdiction
and get a different trial and trying to
undo that verdict and not surprisingly
Jones opposed summary judgment arguing
that there has not been a formal
determination of willful and malicious
injury because the state court findings
were default judgments not full trials
and therefore collateral stopple did not
apply and Jones further argued that the
state court judgments against him were
unfair unconstitutional and the
bankruptcy court should not grant them
full faith and credit by honoring their
validity and in two State specific
rulings against Jones but not his
company us bankruptcy judge Christopher
Lopez of the southern district of Texas
granted partial summary judgment on most
of the issues in favor of the sany hook
plaintiffs while declaring that a few
issues couldn't be summarily resolved
and had to go to trial now under
long-standing Supreme Court precedent
collateral estoppel prevents issues of
fact that were already determined by a
valid and final judgment in a previous
lawsuit for being relitigated in any
subsequent lawsuit that involves the
same parties in bankruptcy court
plaintiffs can invoke collateral stopple
to establish that a debt is
non-dischargeable to determine if
collateral estoppel applies courts
analyze the law of the state in which
the judgments were entered under Texas
law collateral estoppel bars parties
from retiga issues when one the facts
sought to be litigated in the second
action were fully and fairly litigated
in the first action two those facts were
essential to the Judgment in the first
action and the standard for collateral
estoppel in Connecticut is basically the
same with slightly different verbiage
like saying necessary to the judgment
instead of essential now Jones argued
that collateral stopple is inapplicable
because one the precise issue of willful
and malicious conduct was not fully and
fairly litigated since the three default
judgments were entered against him
without trial and two Jones was blocked
for making certain defenses for the
damage his trials and thus denied the
opportunity to fully participate in the
action but the bankruptcy court rejected
those arguments writing that quote
default judgment orders like the ones
entered against Jones have the effect of
fully and fairly adjudicating a claim
and thus the issue of willful and
malicious were properly litigated now
under bankruptcy law debts arising from
Reckless or negligently inflicted
injuries are subject to discharge while
debts arising from an intent to injure
are generally non-dischargeable for an
injury to be the result of willful and
malicious conduct there has to be an
intent to cause the injury not just the
ACT which leads to the injury and to
determine if there was an intent to
cause injury the court has to analyze
from a reasonable person's perspective
whether the defendant's actions were
substantially certain to cause harm and
are such that the court ought to infer
that the dtor subject jective intent was
to inflict a willful malicious injury on
the plaintiff and to illustrate that
distinction Judge Lopez noted that a
debtor's Act of intentionally driving a
car into a crowded bar and killing a
creditor's relatives was found to be
based on willful and malicious injury
while a dtor who illegally sold a rifle
to an individual who years later shot
people did not commit a willful and
malicious injury so in the latter case
the debtor's illegal intent to sell the
rifle was not an act intended to cause
harm to third parties while purposefully
driving a car into a bar clearly does
involve a willful intent to injure and
turning to the Jones matter Judge Lopez
found that the petitions in the Texas
and Connecticut cases contain multiple
clear allegations about Jones's intent
to cause those plaintiffs harm or
substantial certainty that Jones's
actions would cause harm and under Texas
and Connecticut Law all allegations in a
petition are deemed admitted and the
defendant's liability is established if
a default judgment is entered against
the defendant based on a discovery abuse
and you can see in the complaints in
Texas and Connecticut that there are
plenty of allegations that talk about
Jones engaging in willful and
intentional conduct and that's a big
problem for Jones because when you
default in a case it means that you are
deemed to have admitted every single
allegation in that complaint so
accordingly Judge Lopez concluded the
deemed admissions were sufficient to
establish that Jones inflicted willful
and mous injury on the Sandy Hook
plaintiffs and the issue was fully and
fairly litigated for the purposes of
collateral estole and then addressing
the second prong of collateral aole just
Lopez concluded that the finding that
Jones inflicted willful and malicious
injury was necessary and essential to
the and Texas cases Judge Lopez noted
that the juries in the Connecticut and
the hesin Lewis damages trial made
specific factual findings that Jones
acted with an objective certainly of
harm and a subjective motive to cause
harm made quote findings about a
deliberate and intentional act meant to
cause injury not just a deliberate act
that leads to injury and the jury quote
awarded damages based on these findings
and accordingly Judge Lopez granted
summary judgement finding the following
debts are non-dischargeable as a matter
of law including the $965 million in
compensatory damages plus the $150
million in punitive damages from the
Connecticut case and the 4.31 million in
compensatory and exemplary damages in
the hesin Lewis defamation claim however
Judge Lopez found that the record was
not completely clear in some areas
regarding what amounts of other damage
awards were derived from Reckless
conduct which is dischargeable in
bankruptcy as opposed to the intentional
conduct which is not for example the
jury instructions for intentional
infliction of emotional distress in the
hesin Lewis matter said Jones acted
either intentionally or recklessly with
extreme and outrage conduct since the
jury did not differentiate between what
damages flow from Reckless conduct the
debt of which is dischargeable versus
willful and malicious conduct debt of
which is non-dischargeable this issue
couldn't be resolved on summary judgment
so accordingly Judge Lopez denied
summary judgement for in ordered to
trial to resolve what damages stem from
willful and malicious injury versus
Reckless conduct with respect to several
of the intentional infliction of
emotional distress claims uh and the
$321 million in attorney fees awarded as
common law punitive damages in the
Connecticut case now Jones argued that
the judgments against him are
unconstitutional and unfair and thus the
bankruptcy court should refused to honor
the judgments against him he also
asserted that the default judgments
should not be afforded the preclusive
effect of collateral estole claiming
that he was denied the opportunity to
actively participate in litigation due
to the default judgments and was wrongly
prohibited from Raising certain defenses
now the court declined to consider
Jones's argument that the judges were
unconstitutional stating in a footnote
that the state court actions were fully
and fairly litigated with 's
participation and the Supreme Court
requires federal courts to give full
faith and credit to State Court
judgments and jury Awards the court also
rejected Jones's claim that the
Connecticut court judgment was qu skewed
with the intent to obtain a
non-dischargeable judgment in
anticipation of bankruptcy noting qu
there is no evidence of manipulation
that even remotely warrants serious
consideration of this argument based on
the record before the Court Judge Lopez
nonetheless informed Jones that he could
make this argument along with claims
that he was denied the right to make
certain defenses in the appropriate
State Appel courts and addressing
Jones's claim that he was denied the
opportunity to mount a defense Judge
Lopez highlighted that Jones had in fact
participated in all three cases for
multiple years including the presenting
of evidence for the Connecticut and the
hesin Lewis damages trial but chose not
to comply with Discovery orders knowing
full well that he risked default
judgment so Jones has no one to blame
but himself for his own predicament and
explaining why the court will give full
faith and credit to the Connecticut and
Texas default judgments Judge Lopez
quoted the Illinois case of herstein
versus bretman quote where a litigant
participated extensively then failed to
comply with an Express court order
issued multiple times at a risk of
incurring default the litigant should
not now be able to sidestep the
collateral stel Doctrine and litigate an
issue in this forum that was forestalled
in another Court due solely to the
litigant decisions the litigant is not
entitled to a second bite at the Apple
the issue underlying the default
judgment were actually litigated for the
purposes of the collateral stopple
Doctrine so to be clear this Saga is is
far from over I don't know that will
ever be over Jones still has the right
to appeal this ruling in the judgments
in the other cases but this is a
Monumental victory for the plaintiffs
and it's likely that without this ruling
that Jones could have been free to
liquidate the debt saddled Free Speech
systems while being allowed to start
another similar company free from the
Judgment debts this in turn would have
put the San Hook families on the path of
collecting only a fraction of the
awarded damages now the San Hook
families can continue to seek the
maximum amount of recovery and of course
Alex Jones could have avoided all this
drama if he just paid what he owes hey
next time pay your bills but I don't
want to but that's pretty weak tea which
is the opposite of the excellent coffee
that I get from today's sponsor Trade
coffee trade's great because not only do
they have a huge selection of your
favorite coffees but they have a
fine-tune matching process that helps
you discover fresh coffee based on your
taste preferences I have a very specific
taste in coffee I basically want
something that tastes like hot chocolate
and pairs well with milk and trade was
able to find me the perfect bean and
let's be honest you claim you want a
rich dark roast but you really want a
coffee milkshake like I do but but
either way trade has you covered and now
that fall is here it's the perfect time
to drink piping hot coffee or if you're
a crazy person like my friends it's the
perfect time to drink ice cold cold brew
which trade also has a huge selection of
and with trade you can discover new
coffees from the nation's top Roasters
you can choose your coffee rate it and
your coffee suggestions get even better
every time all conveniently delivered
straight to you is really the best
coffee website out there and if you
already know what you like they probably
already have your favorite roaster in
stock at a great price you can even
choose whole beans or your preferred
grind so if you'd like to try Trade
coffee Legal Eagles will get their first
bag free when they sign up all you have
to do is click on the link that's in the
description or the one that's on screen
right now and not only will you get your
first bag free you'll also get free
shipping so get your first bag free by
clicking on the link that's on screen
right now and after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court